[Musica]
alexa siri crystal la segretaria eni e
questa segnatevela la robottina
lavavetri ai di in arrivo dal giappone
tutti questi sono esempi di intelligenza
artificiale
la tecnologia più pervasiva dei prossimi
20 anni
ma c'è un'altra cosa che questi esempi
hanno in comune hanno tutti i volti e
fattezze femminili nell'immaginario
collettivo
i robot sono sempre stati un allegoria
delle classi sfruttate anche la parola e
robot deriva da un termine ceco che
significa schiavo
noi viviamo in un mondo dove 600 milioni
di donne vivono ancora sotto la soglia
della povertà
una su cinque è stata vittima di
violenza
per dare un'idea se ce ne sono 1000 in
questa sala significa 200 donne prima
che io abbia finito di parlare
dieci donne 10 nel mondo
moriranno di quello che dovrebbe essere
il momento più gioioso della loro vita
ovvero il parto mentre assisto
all'avanzata di robot femminili che
lavano le nostre case organizzano le
nostre agende e si prendono cura di noi
con una voce gentile e senza lamentarsi
mai non posso che rabbrividire quando
penso a questi parallelismi anche
microsoft si è cimentata nella sfida
dell'intelligenza artificiale lanciando
thai un bot con le fattezze di un
adolescente gentile progettata per
interagire con gli utenti di twitter
dopo poche ore dal suo lancio thai è
stata subissata di commenti sessisti che
a sua volta ripetuto esponenzialmente in
rete
e prima di venire chiusa solo 16 ore
dopo il suo lancio thai aveva imparato
ad apprezzare hitler
ma come fa tagli ad imparare come ha
fatto come funziona l'intelligenza
artificiale è molto più semplice di
quello che possiamo pensare e dovrebbe
interessarci tutti per capirlo insieme
facciamo un esperimento che cosa vedete
in questa foto colosseo e in questa fin
qui tutto semplice direte voi
in effetti stiamo parlando di un oggetto
simbolo non solo di roma ma dell'umanità
tutta che rimane invariato e per fortuna
almeno quello uguale a se stesso da
qualche migliaio d'anni anche dal punto
di vista geometrico il colosseo è
piuttosto riconoscibile a delle righe
verticali degli archi un ovale nella
prima fase dell'intelligenza artificiale
i ricercatori hanno in effetti fatto
questo cercato di insegnare
all'algoritmo a riconoscere una serie di
forme geometriche
ma che dire allora di questa immagine
per noi ancora facile riconoscerla
ma per un algoritmo si tratta di
aggiungere forme totalmente nuove e un
punto di vista totalmente nuovo cosa
succederebbe se colosseo fosse pieno di
gente o se lo riprendessimo da un'altra
angolazione capite che è estremamente
difficile insegnare una macchina a
pensare con questo metodo solo otto anni
fa
fei fei lì una ricercatrice è
considerata massima esperta di computer
vision la scienza che insegna ai
computer a vedere ha avuto un'intuizione
semplice ma rivoluzionaria è questa
nessuno insegna un bambino a vedere
nessuno insegna un bambino vedere che
banalità e mai questa prima che vi
alziate dalle vostre sedie vi voglio
dire che non è poi così scontato e che
sulla base di questa osservazione
impariamo molto di come noi stessi
apprendiamo così come di come apprendono
le macchine se i nostri occhi fossero un
paio di fotocamere digitali
e sì scatterebbero una foto ogni 200
millisecondi
il tempo medio di un battito di ciglia
quando siamo alti così quando abbiamo
tre anni abbiamo già immagazzinato
milioni di immagini e tutte queste vanno
a costituire una sorta di enciclopedia
digitale sulla quale basiamo il nostro
apprendimento per questo sia pensato che
anziché costruire algoritmi migliori era
sufficiente dare alle macchine sempre
dati se dati sempre più fitti e di
sempre maggior qualità mi manca un po
l'apprendimento dei bambini
ecco perché google è così felice di
ospitare gratuitamente le foto delle
nostre vacanze e le foto dei nostri dei
nostri viaggi o i nostri documenti di
lavoro hanno bisogno dei nostri dati dei
nostri dolci succulenti dati per
alimentare la loro intelligenza
in effetti nel machine learning avere
dati migliori e sempre più preferibile
che costruire algoritmi migliori ma
adesso facciamo un altro passo avanti e
per questo vi chiedo di prendere i
vostri cellulari
avete controllato le email
bene adesso andiamo tutti insieme al suo
motore di ricerca per immagini quello
che preferite e scriviamo ceo la parola
inglese ma ormai di uso internazionale
che denota il numero uno di un'azienda
che cosa vedete ho sentito qualcuno dire
uomini e per le prime 50 o 100 immagini
vedete maschi bianchi
[Musica]
qualcuno tra di voi riesce a vedere un
ceo donna barbie qualcuno tra di voi
vede una sio donna nera 11 lei in fondo
qualcuno tra di voi vedevo sì o disabile
una persona in carrozzina nessuno
nessuno
vedete il pregiudizio non è una cosa
nuova non l'abbiamo inventato noi oggi
quello che è nuovo e che sta avvenendo
inventato oggi è la magnitudine che quel
pregiudizio assume grazie
all'intelligenza artificiale funziona un
pochino così se pensate ad esempio del
bambino è facile capire che le macchine
hanno già disponibilità di molti più
dati di quelli che vediamo noi e li
apprendono molto più velocemente la
maniera in cui funzionano è questa la
macchina trend e diventa più
intelligente poi apprende ancora poi
diventa più intelligente e avanti come
in un otto volante che a ogni giro
aumenta la sua velocità
la rivoluzione dell'apprendimento
automatico è molto diversa dalla
rivoluzione industriale perché questa
non si assesterà sarà sempre più veloce
è qualcosa che non abbiamo mai visto
simile a quello che il matematico wood
teorizzava come esplosione
dell'intelligenza
macché intelligenza sarà che tipo di
intelligenza vogliamo che sia come
poniamo le basi giuste perché
l'intelligenza artificiale ci aiuti e ci
liberi dalle diverse opportunità dovute
ai treni a genere o ricchezza solo
domande difficili ma dobbiamo far modo
che diventino sempre più parte delle
nostre conversazioni
non possiamo chiudere gli occhi e
lasciare che a occuparsene siano solo
gli esperti perché qui siamo chiamati a
determinare come vogliamo che vengano
ma tele intelligenza del futuro e in
ultima analisi in quale tipo di società
vogliamo vivere quando parliamo di un
intelligenza artificiale super
intelligente che migliora se stessa
la nostra unica opportunità è di darle
la giusta diversità divisione e il
giusto la giusta varietà dentro il senso
di dati da cui apprende lasciate che vi
racconti una storia personale nel 2005
mi sono laureata in ingegneria biomedica
e la mia tesi di laurea era un
dispositivo indossabile per prevenire la
caduta negli anziani
il fattore primario che induce a ridotta
mobilità e quindi all'indebolimento e
alla morte per realizzarla avevo
costruito un sistema elettronico di tre
touch e le rom e tri tri assiali
collegati a una maglietta della salute
degli accelerometri trasmettevano i loro
dati di posizione e io andavo integrarli
in un algoritmo di previsione della
caduta ho coinvolto tutti i miei
compagni di corso che vedete sotto nel
durante le elezioni e poi a
ringraziamento per avermi aiutata tutti
erano chiamati a simulare le più
svariate cadute chi camminando sul tapis
roulant inciampando che fingendo di
svenire chi cadendo dalle scale sono
stati lunghi mesi di lavoro a 15 giorni
dalla consegna degli elaborati
niente ancora l'algoritmo non andava
poi una sera me lo ricordo come se fosse
ieri bingo l'algoritmo aveva cominciato
a prendere e riusciva a prevedere la
caduta prima dell'impatto con una buona
accuratezza e soprattutto si migliorava
mano a mano che lo alimentava con nuovi
dati è abbastanza imbarazzante a
metterlo adesso di fronte a duemila
persone a tutti quelli che ci guardano
in streaming ma adesso so che avevo
costruito un ottimo strumento per la
prevenzione delle cadute solo degli
uomini
in effetti io avevo usato i miei
compagni di corso
sarebbe funzionato altrettanto bene se
avessi preso delle donne se avessi avuto
varietà nel mio cetto di dati non ne
sono così sicura
comunque mi sono laureata e poi ho
cominciato a cercare lavoro
non sorprendentemente il profilo di
ingegnere biomedico specializzato in
cadute non era primo nei motori di
ricerca e lo sapete nemmeno il profilo
di ingegnera è primo nei motori di
ricerca le ricercatrici della carnegie
mellon university hanno effettuato uno
studio sui lavori ad alto reddito
pubblicati online
se una donna riceve in media 300
visualizzazioni per questi annunci un
uomo ne riceve 1800 questa cosa potrebbe
essere una colpa delle aziende che usano
come target per i lavori ad alto reddito
solo gli uomini ma la discrepanza è così
ampia che viene più facile pensare ad un
algoritmo deviato e che alimenta se
stesso e adesso vi chiedo siamo davvero
disposti anche a decidere il lavoro che
andrà a fare la nostra bambina sia un
algoritmo che la discrimina perché il
suo genere non è rappresentato nelle
stanze in cui viene costruito davvero
quello che vogliamo è che le cadute dei
nonni siano più prevedibili e che quindi
i nonni vengano curati prima e meglio
delle nonne se ammettiamo che
l'elaborazione delle informazioni è la
fonte delle opportunità
allora dobbiamo anche pensare che solo
portando più varietà all'interno delle
comunità che programmano l'intelligenza
artificiale
avremo una tecnologia più giusta e una
società più equa ma la varietà da sola
non basta vi racconta un'altra storia
personale la mia amica chiara una donna
eccezionale si è fatta strada in un
ambiente estremamente competitivo
diventando la numero uno della sua
azienda chiara anche una persona
sensibile e ha conosciuto momenti duri
come quelli dovuti alla depressione
promuovere una persona come chiara senza
guardare al suo genere
la sua provenienza appare sicuramente
giusto e credo che sembra condivisibile
usare un algoritmo per farlo perché
quale maniera migliore di levare
soggettività a questa decisione
esiste un'azienda americana che è in
grado di desumere qualsiasi cosa su di
noi usando le nostre briciole digitali
le informazioni che lasciamo sparsa in
rete senza nemmeno accorgersene
in particolare sono in grado di predire
la depressione mesi prima mesi prima che
insorga qualsiasi sintomo
naturalmente il loro intento è quello di
intercettare malessere quando è ancora
piccolo appena curabile adesso vi chiedo
di pensare un attimo a chiara quali
sarebbero le implicazioni morali e
sociali
se lasciassimo che a decidere fosse un
algoritmo che pensa a noi dalle nostre
briciole digitali da quello che facciamo
su facebook su twitter sulla rete solo
un con una comunità scientifica più
inclusiva e rappresentativa di tutti i
generi e di tutte le minoranze
riusciremo a mantenere un controllo
etico sull'intelligenza artificiale
mantenzione gli algoritmi non devono
essere una scusa per abdicare alla
nostra responsabilità personale bensì
un'opportunità per costruire un
intelligenza collettiva planetaria
inclusiva e partecipata
grazie
[Applauso]